les trois jours du président giscard
d'estaing en corse
la violence est incompatible avec la
liberté l'exode des chinois du vietnam
du vietnam tmt shipping l'attitude des
vietnamiens et vicieuse les enfants de
l'oubli adoption et parrainage pour les
sortir de leur solitude
une grande enquête de monique carats en
avant-première pour antenne 2 la
dernière chanson de gilbert bécaud
un constat son titre quand je ne serai
plus là messieurs bonsoir dans quelques
minutes valéry giscard d'estaing va
quitter la corse
d'ailleurs vous le voyez son hélicoptère
est déjà prêt à mon avis il me semble
même déjà être en train de partir c'est
donc la fin d'un voyage officiel de
trois jours là bas alors pour respecter
les aspirations et disons le les
susceptibilités des uns et des autres la
visite ce qui avait commencé à ajaccio
s'est achevée à bastia aujourd'hui ils
prennent la république a d'abord laissé
le temps aux corses de s'imprégner des
mesures qui leur a annoncé hier mesure
apparemment bien perçu bien reçu il a
aussi rendu un hommage particulier à la
légion basez vous le savez à calvi en
serrant la main du colonel erulin et en
disant aux paras du 2e rep son régiment
merci messieurs
mission accomplie et puis surtout un
réquisitoire une charge très durs contre
la violence la journée du chef de l'état
en corse avec la nos envoyés spéciaux
ligue 1 le président de la république
pour reculer aujourd'hui sa découverte
de la corse profonde et il a pu voir au
fond des yeux des personnes qu'il a
rencontrées que les mesures décidées à
ajaccio avait porté la vie quotidienne
sera améliorée on le sait maintenant des
empreintes de nombreux crédits dégagés
non pas sous forme d'aumône mais plutôt
d'une aide efficace qui devrait
permettre aux corses d'envisager
l'avenir avec confiance
a calvi première étape de la journée le
colonel erulin qui revient du zaïre a
été présenté au président de la
république qui a félicité le 2e rep
je voudrais lui adresser le message qui
me paraît le mieux adapté à ses qualités
de soldat et à son courage récents dans
l'action qui est de lui dire ici à calvi
mission accomplie à corte ville de la
future université corse le président a
réaffirmé la nécessité du dialogue entre
les élus et le gouvernement afin que les
propres problèmes corse soit pris en
main par les corses et non par les
citadelles administratives les problèmes
seront donc réglée dans le cadre de la
république ce qui met fin aux
spéculations de ceux qui demandaient un
statut spécial un nouveau coup de
semonce pour ceux qui espéraient faire
entendre leur voix
avec le plastique
en fin d'après midi à bastia
le président de la république passe les
troupes en revue les parachutistes du 2e
rep sont encore à l'honneur
peu après dans son discours le chef de
l'état évoque longuement un sujet qui le
touche celui de la violence
elle est injustifiable en démocratie
c'est un moyen de pression sans effet
sur lui et sur les institutions
c'est une forme d'action qui au total
atteint surtout la corse aujourd'hui
dans ses biens et demain dans son âme
lorsqu'on peut s'exprimer lorsqu'on peut
décider librement par son vote
quelle est l'utilité de la violence
croissante ont exercé une pression sur
le pouvoir central en comptant sur sa
défaillance
je préviens que ce genre de pression est
sans effet sur moi
attentifs vous le savez aux observations
respectueux du suffrage libéral au point
que certains me le reproche je suis par
contre allergique à toute forme de
pression et en particulier aux chants
danses de la violence
alors cette violence je vous le demande
qui atteint tel en réalité elle atteint
les biens et l'âme de la corse
peut-on vraiment dans ses expéditions
précautionneuse où l'on va la nuit en
rasant les murs déposer du plastique
volée à la porte d'un garage d'un café
au risque de mutiler un passant ou un
innocent peut-on vraiment se croire une
âme de héros
où est l'honneur dans ses expéditions
furtive et ouais la tradition
d'hospitalité
quand le but inavouable est de chasser
par la terreur
nos compatriotes continentaux et pieds
noirs qui vivent dans votre île il faut
mettre fin à la violence
il faut le faire ensemble
il faut le faire pour la corse
l'état a des devoirs d'un remplir devoir
de sécurité devoir de justice
je donne instruction à tous ceux qui en
ont la responsabilité d'accomplir leur
mission avec fermeté et dans la justice
mais je compte aussi sur les corps c'est
à eux c'est à elle de conduire la
désescalade de la violence en faisant
comprendre à ce qu'une passion mal
comprises ou des influences troubles a
pu entraîner que la violence dessert la
cause de ceux qui l'emploient qu'elle ne
peut entraîner ni leurs convictions ni
leur estime et qu'elle blesse
durablement l'âme et l'honneur de la
corse il n'y a pas un problème corse il
ya des problèmes de la corse
cette formule utilisée par le président
de la république ce matin à corte au
coeur de la montagne corse résume bien
je crois ce qu'était sa démarche tout au
long de ce voyage de trois jours qui
s'achève ce soir il ya des problèmes de
la corse problèmes économiques sociaux
culturels humains et le président de la
république a annoncé une série de
mesures mais il précise bien que les
solutions doivent être recherchées dans
un cadre français dans le cadre des
institutions françaises et cette
préoccupation il l'a exprimé sur des
tons différents chaque jour est même
presque à chaque étape d avant-hier dans
son premier discours d'ajaccio et
insisté sur le rôle primordial que
doivent jouer les élus du suffrage
universel
hier toujours ajaccio est précisément
devant ces élus il soulignait que le
droit commun s'appliquait à la corse
comme il s'applique à tous les
départements français et l'unité
disent-ils et d'autres forces et il a
ajouté je crois avec un certain sourire
intérieur que cette conception unitaire
la république la tenais en héritage du
plus illustre des corses et aujourd'hui
sur cette grande place saint-nicolas de
bastia c'était un discours d'une gravité
et d'une ferme était exceptionnel contre
le recours à la violence
bref pour le président de la république
le problème politique posé par la corse
n'a pas d'autre solution politique que
l'unité nationale
ce problème se résoudra disparaîtra
d'ailleurs de lui-même lorsque
disparaîtront les raisons des
mécontentements
c'est à la fois un parti et un
engagement de petits nuages quand même
pour le chef de l'état en corse et
critique de jacques chirac hier contre
la politique étrangère je suis peinée
par ses propos excessifs a dit le
président il l'a dit aux parlementaires
rpr qui l'accompagné dans son voyage et
puis une petite baisse de popularité la
cote de valéry giscard d'estaing rest
hôte mais baisse de 3 points vous le
voyez 50% de satisfaits et contre 33 %
chez les mécontents du côté de son
premier ministre la chute est plus forte
encore six points de moins
37 % pour les satisfaits et nous le
disent
l'ifop et françoise 49% pour les
mécontents alors ils ont social en
revanche des nuages paraissent un petit
peu moins noir au début de la semaine
c'est le statut krouchi renault les 200
ouvriers des presses ont réoccupé leur
atelier à flins alors que les 20000
salariers reprenait le travail
la cgt a annoncé qu'elle envisageait de
nouvelles formes d'action cette nuance
est la conséquence d'une situation très
variable selon les différentes villes
renault enfin chez bernier les 250
cariste en grève ont cessé l'occupation
de l'usiné de vénissieux mort d'un
sénateur là un sénateur par dont la nuit
dernière
léopold hébert était sénateur socialiste
de la guyane la politique étrangère
maintenant avec d'abord un raid
israélien au sud liban
quatre jours avant la date fixée pour
l'évacuation totale de cette partie du
territoire par les forces israéliennes
un commando appuyées par des
hélicoptères ont attaqué une base navale
palestinienne entre saïda et tire pour
tel aviv plusieurs dizaines de
palestiniens auraient été tuées au cours
de ce raid qualifié de préventif car
cette base devait servir de point de
départ à une action imminente de
fedayins sur les côtes israéliennes
il y aurait eu quelques morts du côté
comment dans un conflit larvé est en
train d'éclater au grand jour dans
l'extrême orient communiste la querelle
entre la chine et le vietnam
thank you ping le vice premier ministre
chinois est même allé jusqu'à qualifier
de vicieuses l'attitude de ces
vietnamiens auquel pékin avait pourtant
fourni une grande assistance dans le
passé alors pourquoi tout cela
l'explication de philippe rochon ils
sont plus de cent mille cent mille
chinois du vietnam qui ont déjà pris en
deux
le chemin de l'exode chaque jour un
millier de réfugiés franchissent la
frontière entre le vietnam et la chine
et gagne la province chinoise du yunnan
commerçants artisans établie depuis des
dizaines d'années ils ont parfois tout
laisser pour fuir le vietnam face à la
psychose des persécutions qui règne
parmi la communauté chinoise et qui
n'est pas démentie par les derniers
réfugiés politiques vietnamiens
les u à les chinois installés au vietnam
étaient près de 2 millions il jouait un
rôle capital dans l'économie du pays et
n'est pratiquement tout le petit
commerce chollon le quartier chinois de
saigon était une véritable ville
chinoise
on l'avait surnommé le cancer du sud
même un an après l'entrée des forces
communistes à saïgon le commerce et le
trafic de toutes sortes whisky passeport
n'avait pas perdu leurs droits
en adoptant de nouvelles mesures contre
le trafic et la corruption en
nationalisant le petit commerce en
changeant la monnaie les autorités
vietnamiennes savait que la communauté
chinoise serait frappé la première mais
les chinois du vietnam font surtout les
frais des tensions politiques entre la
chine qui soutient le cambodge contre le
vietnam et le vietnam qui est soutenue
de plus en plus par l'union soviétique
les chinois ont tous obtenu d'économie
bons et il ya eu pendant
des dizaines d'années les chinois he
n'avait pas de problème avec les bêtas
mien on vivait entre nous bon il y avait
des petites jalousies mais au fond c'est
pas ça alors le communiste veut changer
de commune ils n'ont pas solution de
rechange
on peut pas détruire les comiques comme
ça n'ont pas de solution de rechange
bon ils essayent comment maîtriser ou 10
à persécuter les chinois je crois si tu
c'est une question très dangereuse et
vous avez l'impression qu'à travers les
chinois du vietnam c'est pékin qui est
attaqué par le gouvernement vietnamien
oui c'est sûr parce que vous avez fait
qu'un ne peut pas accepter les régimes
dits et amiens trop trop trop rapprochés
des russes à ce qui se rapporte aux
russes automatiquement des designers
doivent s'aider des bases militaires et
sa ferme rochus pour les ailes pour le
chinois est super seront jamais ça les
armées des deux pays se renforce tout
frontières la chine a décidé de réduire
de moitié son aide économique au vietnam
hanoi vient pourtant d'autoriser les
bateaux chinois à pénétrer dans les
ports de saigon et de haïphong pour
évacuer les réfugiés les chinois du
vietnam savent qu'ils ne pourront
refaire en chine les mêmes affaires ou
vietnam
la mort dans l'âme 400 mille d'entre eux
seraient pourtant volontaire pour
l'exode
oui si tu es tout et leur tube ping je
le fais à nouveau maintenant car les
propos qu'il vient de tenir aujourd'hui
ne sont guère rassurants une troisième
guerre mondiale est inévitable at il dit
chili une commission spéciale des
nations unies pour à étudier sur place
la situation des droits de l'homme là
bas ainsi en a décidé le gouvernement du
général pinochet qui décidément assoupli
sa férule en ce moment on verra bien
s'il s'agit d'une amorce de
libéralisation ou bien de simples
artifices de l'autre côté de la
cordillère des andes
l'argentine la police a interrompu
aujourd'hui une manifestation de mère et
de femme de disparus à buenos aires et
il se confirme que l'on devrait avoir
très prochainement des nouvelles des
disparus français ce sont les
responsables du football tricolore qui
l'ont annoncé par ailleurs le capitaine
de l'équipe allemande e
dartybox a refusé de recevoir une
médaille que voulait lui remettre un
mouvement argentin favorable à la junte
faut maintenant revenir sur les actes de
vandalisme qui hier matin ont endommagé
plusieurs stations de métro à paris 62
appareils de contrôle automatique des
billets ont été mis hors service
célébrations n'ont pas été directement
revendiqué mais beaucoup y retrouve la
patte de ce que l'on appelle les
autonomes ces bandits organisés qui se
situe en marge de toute idéologie
politique mais qui refusent un certain
nombre de contraintes de la société
périodiquement sporadiquement il
réveille l'actualité sans qu'on sache
trop comment les classes et comment les
comprendre c'est pourtant ce qu'a essayé
de faire patricia cost éléments
incontrôlés casseurs anarchiste
intellectuelle petits enfants de mai 68
on trouve de tout chez les autonome
sauf une organisation derrière le front
uni des casseurs de vitrine
il fonctionne par petits groupes de
trois à trente personnes grand maximum
certains leur littérature
et dans chaque opuscule une vision
parfois différente de l'autonomie
certains ont un embryon d'histoire et au
moins deux dates de naissances mâles
ville et la bataille nucléaire
la mort de bader et de ses amis un trait
commun à tous
le rejet est même le combat du gauchisme
du militantisme considérés comme des
échecs et l'appel sur tous les plans à
des pratiques plus radicale nous la
violence d'abord on se détermine pas
spécialement par rapport à la violence
on se détermine par rapport à
l'offensive c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
on nous a parqué dans un certain espace
qui est fait de loi qui est fait d'un
consensus social politique et c'est
qu'on refuse que par rapport à toutes
ces lois par rapport à ses niveaux de
l'égalité c'est sûr qu'on pratique
l'offensive sur tous les fronts et qu'on
ne veut plus maintenant pleurer des
pétitions les manifestations pour
demander les miettes qu'on veut bien
nous lâchant on prend ce qu'on a envie
de prendre aujourd'hui
ce qui ne signifie pas forcément piller
voler mais comme en italie occupé des
maisons vides ça fonctionnait des radios
pirates pratiques et l'absentéisme
refusé les augmentations de prix pour
vous progressez commencé à vivre
aujourd'hui la révolution dans les
rapports qu'on a dans les choses qu'on
fait par rapport à satisfaire ses désirs
et ses les satisfaire si on veut qu
est-ce qui était change réellement qu'on
ne retrouve pas comme si c'est pas son
union soviétique avec une révolution qui
a ramené à une société qu encore pire
que c'est que celle qui en france
aujourd'hui
qui encore plus autoritaire encore plus
concentrationnaire il faut commencer la
révolution maintenant dans nos pratiques
alors c'est essayer de comprendre ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui pour voir quel
sera le problème c'est ça veut dire
qu'on peut lire ceci le demain on essaye
de voir comment on ferait plaisir
aujourd'hui déjà pour nous les méga le
rouge section découper du port autonome
faire l'assassinât tuer quelqu'un
froidement pour donner un exemple on
nous a aucune signification c'est
reproduire les schémas les schémas de
pensée à raisonnement qui est celui de
la bourgeoisie mais il ya la face cachée
de l'autonomie plus dur plus jeunes ou
des chômeurs de 20 ans les travailleurs
intérimaires faut vendre et c'est
nouveau
avec des immigrés et des délinquants qui
eux commencent à se politiser
c'est parmi ces autonomes ou dur que
l'on voit maintenant apparaître des
armes dans les manifestations ce qu'on
cherche à s'organiser entre d'entre eux
jeune prometteur entre autres jeunes
ouvriers pour justement pour justement
nous préparer à affronter l'état et la
sphère notre politique
notre politique c'est à dire être
autonome
combien sont ils difficile à dire de
quelques centaines à quelques milliers
estime-t-on à partir de la semaine
prochaine
antenne 2 a décidé de lancer une grande
campagne sur les enfants de l'oubli les
enfants délaissés tous les jours à 18h40
dans l'émission de noël mamère c'est la
vie nous essaierons de vous faire vivre
la réalité quotidienne d'un drame qui
marque beaucoup d'enfants abandonnés
il faut savoir d'abord que le mot
orphelinat n'existe plus il est remplacé
par des centres où les enfants adoptés
trop toi l'école d'autres enfants qui
eux ont la chance d'avoir des parents
mais tous ces enfants là ne sont pas
adoptables certains ont encore des
parents qui les voit et assez rarement
et c'est d'abord cela que nous voulons
aider en vous demandant de nous écrire
pour les distraire pour les sortir pour
changer un peu leur vie
est ce que tu te plaît là bas au centre
tu sais pourquoi tu y es
j'ai pas parce qu'il ya des choses que
je sais un accueil chez pas angéla et
est l'aîné de trois sa maman est décédée
d'une phase souvent dramatiques
le papa qui a beaucoup qui a une
situation assez précaire conservé de
très forts liens affectifs avec ses cris
ont pu via les jours il vient les voir
tous les dimanches et quand son travail
ne lui permet pas de venir le dimanche
il vient les voir dans la semaine et met
sur je me lis ne les sors jamais étant
donné le fait qu'il n'a pas de logement
ce que j'aimerais mal que tout retourner
dans sa famille
tu le demandes at-on pop en jeu mais une
petite fille qui a toujours là connu la
collectivité depuis la mort de sa maman
mais qui est assez bien adapté à la
collectivité
à l'école elle est très bien accueilli
comme tout autre enfant de l'école et
elle se fait des amis comme n'importe
quel enfant et en particulier sa
petite-amie annabelle l'invite de temps
en temps pour un goûter avec d'autres
petits amis de l'école le mieux oui
c'est mon meilleur ami est inséparable
tout le temps oui je vous conte semble
et comment t'es venue l'idée de
l'inviter chez toi ben parce que je
voulais jouer avec elle j'aime bien le
fait que ce soit aussi dans une fonction
qu on en fait ça nagerait corps humain
ah ouais
la dernière j'avais une fille calme en
certaines années j'en ai plusieurs
commencent à se presser pour à peu près
pareil on ne sent pas que jamais qui ont
des problèmes affectifs au sein de leur
famille videmment mais qui à l'école ont
un comportement normal et qui travaille
bien assez selon d'une façon générale
c'est quand même pas d'un niveau très
relevé il ya des problèmes agricoles
étant donné que les enfants ont souvent
suite aux expériences qu'elles ont vécue
en famille ces retards scolaires et des
blocages et le certains professeurs sont
amenés à rejeter nos enfants à cause de
ce retard à cause de ces blocages ce que
tu as d'autres petites amies comme ça
l'école qui t'invite david pas je pense
qu'angers cas auraient besoin d'être
parrainés mais il faudrait à ce moment
là que ça se fasse en accord avec le
père pour moduler le
les sorties et les vacances par rapport
à l'emploi du temps du père des enfants
ne sont pas adoptables
mais on peut faire entreprendre un moyen
terme avec le parrainage les forêts
c'est là qu'ils m'ont beaucoup aidé à
parrainer
on a davantage de détails sur ces
parrainages cette opération antenne 2 à
partir de la semaine prochaine tous les
jours à 18h 40 ainsi que dans la croix
et télé 7 jours déclin des disciplines
littéraires au concours général la cuvée
60 18 et plutôt moyenne près de la
moitié des prix n'ont pas été décernés
platini sur la touche pour france
hongrie michel hidalgo a fait cela pour
permettre aux 22 tricolores sélectionnés
pour l'argentine de tous joué pendant le
mondial ainsi demain soir mar del plata
vous pourrez voir dropsy bracci petit et
papilles tous ne sont pas corse - de la
main sur quatre seulement et puis pour
ceux qui aiment écrire l'histoire avec
des six voilà de quoi vous retournez les
entrailles figurez-vous que l' arbitre
suisse de france-argentine reconnaît
aujourd'hui avoir sifflé par erreur le
penalty contre marius trésor
après avoir revu plusieurs fois l'action
à la télévision at il dit je me dis
qu'aujourd'hui je ne siffle rep ah mais
comme deep ou de coluche on a bien perdu
il n'y a plus de représentant de fer
françaises à roland garros brigitte
simon a été éliminé en demi finale des
internationaux de france en deux manches
en trois manches par don par la roumaine
ne vous ai dit
quant à la finale du double messieurs
qui opposait les espagnols andrés
higueras aux américains pisterait mayer
elle a vu la victoire de ces derniers en
trois manches et fois
départ demain des 24 heures du mans 46e
du nom une cinquantaine de concurrents
seront pas ce rendez vous qui n'a pas
toujours été au cours dé la navigation à
la hauteur de la réputation des preuves
le cru 78 renouera lui avec la tradition
des grands duels
un match qui promet porsche renault
vainqueur dernière édition l'écurie
porsche est venue cette année avec
quatre voitures officielles trois
parties est une voiture fermée
délicatement surnommée la baleine
blanche en 77 et et renault le
challenger cette année on les squares
volontiers chez porsche que les français
sont favoris enfin la modestie mais dès
les premiers essais jacky ickx pulvérisé
le record officieux du circuit en
réalisant plus de 236 km heure de
moyenne sur un tour techniquement
cependant on prend un risque chez
porsche en tentant de faire gagner un
moteur entièrement nouveau et pourtant
les pilotes et les responsables de
l'équipe ne paraissent pas spécialement
préoccupé
chez renault on a également travaillé
pour améliorer les performances et la
fiabilité des voitures par rapport à
l'an dernier
on a surtout essayé de mettre au point
un système de bulle aérodynamique
permettant de gagner en vitesse de
pointe
gérard larousse est sûre de ses voitures
pourtant dès les premiers essais des
résultats n'étaient pas là
la vitesse de pointe 380 à l'heure dans
la ligne droite est d'ailleurs une
préoccupation pour les pilotes ainsi que
l'expliquent jean pierre jabouille
c'est certain que dans cette ligne
droite il faut aller assez vite mais
quand on atteint sa vitesse là c'est un
peu trop rapide et je crois qu'il faut
mieux utiliser la voiture d'une autre
manière par la puissance du moteur en
mettant un petit peu plus d'appuis
aérodynamiques sur la voiture parce que
dans le trafic on est beaucoup plus à
l'aise là il ya trop de différences
entre les voitures lentes et l'autre
voiture qui est vraiment très rapide
mais 24 heures du mans course
d'endurance plus maintenant c'est une
course de vitesse qui dure longtemps et
c'est la meilleure interprétation de ce
distinguo qui permettra à l'une ou
l'autre équipe de s'imposer dimanche
après midi
la météo pour terminer il a fait chaud
sur la france aujourd'hui moyenne des
températures supérieures à 20 degrés
vous allez découvrir avec notre autre
caméra des nuages sur la moitié nord et
des orages sur la moitié sud alors
demain maintenant demain samedi donc de
beau temps ensoleillé sur la moitié nord
vous le découvrez avec beaucoup de
nuages sur la moitié sud et même
quelques orages en montagne et sur les
régions méditerranéennes
dimanche c'est bien dimanche sera une
vraie journée d'été du soleil sur
pratiquement tout le pays avec seulement
quand même quelques orages sur le
pourtour de la méditerranée dernière
édition du journal aux alentours de 23
heures elle sera présentée par bernard
ap
un autre rendez vous demain à 12h30
samedi ennemis présenté par jean claude
mongeau le thème de l'émission les gros
et puis avant de nous séparer
écoutons ensemble dernier bébé qu un
monsieur cent mille volts qui n'a rien
perdu de son dynamisme et qui a mis un
tel enthousiasme dans l'enregistrement
de ses nouvelles chansons pour le top
club de guy ducrey semaine prochaine
qu'il s'est brisé le pied
sa dernière composition s'appelle quand
je ne serai plus là voilà quand à moi je
serai là lundi bonsoir à tous nos jeunes
m
soit la moitié
de mon âme
toi qui étais plus que jours
je prends les sentiers
coca
ce soir c'est la fin de tout
avant
le toit
tu as
on
ma vie 120
l e petit e
merci j'ai rien compris
mais j'ai un plan
suri
à dix
comptez sur moi
chez
plus là
j'vais
toujours
quand boucher
là